you're ready for Thanksgiving before you
eat that turkey I want to bust one myth
you've heard about that Thanksgiving
feast Pilgrims and Indians sharing food
sharing is nice in families and
sometimes in small groups but it's
Thanksgiving approaches let's remember
that when we pilgrims first came to
America we almost starved people grew
weak and thin some swelled with hunger
that's because we settlers acted like
Bernie Sanders wants us to act we farmed
collectively the corporation that funded
our expedition said grow food together
divide the harvest equally bad idea
communal farming creates what economists
call the tragedy of the Commons think
about a nice piece of land that ranchers
hold in common anyone who wants to can
bring their cattle to graze the tragedy
is that no individual Rancher is much
motivated to try to preserve that land
in fact every rancher has the incentive
to bring more and more cattle to the
pastures so they're gonna continue to
add cow after cow until the pasture is
over grazed and destroyed one way to
demonstrate that is to run experiments
like this one this is now your property
here I assembled a group of people and
told them the circle is your shared land
you can furnish it with fries people
whatever and they did then I put some
fake coins on their property and told
them each coin is worth a buck but if
you can leave it in there for a minute
I'll give you two bucks each minute it
doubles in value if they can wait they
can make much more money do they wait
ready set go
nobody waited there was no reason to
wait someone else would just grab your
coins let's change the rules of the game
I divided the land into segments so each
person had his own property then we
played the game again same rules every
minute the value doubles except you can
only take coins from your property go
nobody's doing anything why are you
waiting
I want to reap the most benefit you
didn't wait last time at that moment I
wanted it now whereas this is going up
in it's mine you know exactly when you
own property
you take care to preserve it to allow it
to keep producing good things but we
pilgrims shared our lands so when the
crops were ready to harvest we did what
these people did some of my neighbors
sneaked out at night and grabbed extra
food some picked corn before it was
fully ready the result by the spring our
food stores what are you was it not the
shortage of food was worse because of a
second problem with the Commons when you
share the results of your work some
people don't work hard for it let an
opportunity for some to take advantage
and leave the work to others have that
continued Thursday would be known as
starvation day but fortunately we were
led not by Bernie Sanders or other
Commons loving socialists but by
Governor William Bradford who wrote in
his diary after much debate ie William
Bradford assign it to every family a
parcel of land he did what I did here
the result this had very good success
for it made all hands very industrious
we brought in a harvest that was more
than enough to feed us after such a
success we never returned to shared
planting private property allowed us
pilgrims to prosper and have that feast
we read about at school so this
Thanksgiving if you have a good meal
think private property every day it
protects us from the tragedy of the
Commons
you